24 year old you don't know about
life as all 24 year olds you have hubris
that's your downfall you would be so
much more open receptive and respectable
if you had some humility exactly you
need to have humility I have more
humility I have more humility than you
do do you see what it's such a difficult
thing to say literally just did it one
up I said I have more humility than you
don't you see that that's an ironic
statement you are being such a hypocrite
unbelievable you said I have more
humility than you like do you see how
stupid that is
[Music]
like you you're in all of your content
is hateful look at it look at oh my God
I'm the traditional male that you dream
I'm married I've got kids I'm rich I run
my own business don't you think you
should be asking me for advice